foreign
New Jersey schools try to stem kids
identifying as they and them the number
of New Jersey public school students who
identify as non-binary is up four
thousand percent since 2019. hell I can
remember the good old days when most New
Jersey public school students identified
as felons
anyway during the 2019-20 school year
just 16 kids in the Garden State
identified as non-binary compared to
675 students in 2023
675 that's almost as high as Jesse's SAT
score
maybe got eight o'clock can you believe
that he got eight o'clock what's he got
what does it mean and why would all
these kids want to do this well first it
tells you that it's not real if suddenly
everyone announced their ceiling fans
and there's no change in the environment
that led to that announcement you can
bet it's purely a social contagion and
why is it contagious well it's an
elective action that brings young people
initial positive attention you become
noticed and feel super special and
important and that's all young people
want and even better there's no risk
just reward you don't have to play
sports or learn to skateboard or play in
a band just change your pronoun and
you're in hell you might even get a
parade right
and the only people who aren't welcome
are your parents what do they know
they're just some stupid breeders
well I really ended on the down around
I've never heard them make that noise
before yeah yeah it sounded like
somebody was excising like a little mole
or yeah or like when I'm eating dinner
my dog wants like a piece of chicken
I'll give it to him yeah
that was weird that was like that was a
I think I've that's our first group
grown cat
um this is interesting I think we do
know that this is just to get attention
because there's no explanation this is a
social contagion no I mean it's I think
it's just a it's a total coincidence
yeah
yeah no but people are gonna say that
yeah yeah people are going to say that
because unfortunately we've reached a
point where okay if like it's a gonna be
a conservative or Fox News that's going
to be saying what you're saying that
maybe it's not a coincidence therefore
the other side's got to lean hard into
it totally is you're not allowed to have
your own opinion you just have to prove
how different you are from the other
side because you say that give them any
ground then you're one of them and then
you're completely excommunicated
obviously I I don't even know what this
it this was when I was in elementary
school and I think most people didn't
and I think a lot of this is a
distraction too from the fact that there
has been so much learning lost during
covet and there's been no accountability
for that um good point
you have three kids right Jamie I think
their pronouns are leave us alone
you came up with that their pronouns are
whose and he
um
yeah I don't I'm scared I get scared
about this topic I'm gonna be I'm not
the smart I didn't even know percentages
went up to 4 000.
um
I thought I thought a hunter was all of
it no you know what's interesting
no it's very it's such a great point
this is such a great point because like
when something goes up 100 that could
just be like uh one out of a little bit
so it's a two out of a hundred yes like
I said one person out of 100 at a heart
attack and then on the drug yeah two had
a heart attack that's yeah 100 increase
I'm like it's three thousand percent
bigger she's like it's still only three
inches
[Laughter]
I was like there's no way he'll make
this about his penis
I was wrong I'm sorry
I just got in trouble I think last time
I didn't know what binary meant I looked
it up and it's like gender fluid yeah
which I thought gender fluid was like
why we needed a towel after sex I said
something like that and um I don't think
he could do it again I've learned my
lesson you haven't learned any lessons I
will never make when did Jamie all of a
sudden go Blue
like he was always the nice comic and
now everything's about genitals your
brain you know you're turning you're
bringing this show to The Gutter and now
my job I'm looking at my jokes I'm
looking at my jokes and they all just
say penis one through five
trying to figure out
I don't know
I don't know I don't know if these words
mean like not not binary I don't
bisexual I thought meant you paid for
sex
um
you're only encouraging this imagine
being bisexual though how exhausting
that would be to look at everyone's ass
yeah
all right let's say walk there there you
go so you know Emily I find it in I I
like the pronouns because they tell me
who I would never hire like if that was
on a resume I would be like you're gone
also I do believe that anybody that
adopted this uh it it tells you that
you're a non-playing character in the
world because if you were so easily LED
that you would accept this that means
you aren't actually participating in
your own destiny what do you think of
that lady face yes it is an indicator
just not the kind that they think they
are indicating right it's sending the
message that they're just annoying
yourself yeah here's the thing about
this to me there's two points about this
number one yes they're kids they're
teenagers and therefore everything is
infectious everything is spread now I'm
Blitz here everything
um they do what everyone else is doing
exactly that's the whole point it's like
the laughter epidemic of 1962 and now
Tanzania that lasted months the whole
point is if you put kids together they
are going to do all the same thing and
the second point is that this is
absolutely being encouraged not only by
the ridiculous climate we're now living
in but literally retail you know we've
talked about this with a Target there
are entire lines it's a multi-million
dollar industry with shirts that say ask
me about my pronouns that with cards
that say I'm so happy I'm so proud that
you came out they are being rewarded for
being part of that club because
otherwise then they don't get that merch
otherwise they can't wear that t-shirt
otherwise they're left alone simply by
being normal yeah that's not enough
anymore so read a book that's what I say
read a book and if you're blind get it
in braille
right Tom yes don't use that blind
excuse on me
no I think that's great
but the uh I think that we had
counterculture you know there's a
certain uh percentage of students that
are going to want to go against the
grain and I think in the early 70s you
had the kind of hippies right yeah The
Counter Culture and then when we were in
high school Greg you had the punks yeah
you know you would spike your hair up
maybe somebody you'd get an earring
maybe a tattoo dye their hair things
like that that was very radical back
then that doesn't even get you attention
anymore no and now they actually get
they reward you for it well they'll say
on the morning announcements now uh you
know a transgender can use the uh the
locker room of your choice and the boys
are like oh yeah I'm definitely uh I'm
trans yeah I'm trans I'm going to use
the girls locker room uh but yeah I
think it's just give give the give them
the choice it's part of this big
National conversation and a national
fight and you can be seen as tolerant if
you're part of this group so yes so it
is people take advantage of it I've seen
trans people use the bathroom in first
class when they're in coach the
Horrors see it works and that's what
really gets you Greg when they walk by
you in first class and you say you have
a coach seat what are you doing
just made that old story up because I
was thinking it's such a great story
people become trans to use First Class
bathroom
let's make that up so they have it on
Fox and Friends tomorrow
they stole our our mirror all right up
next from ugly dogs to a talented cow
local news is coming up now
will be in the New York area and would
like free tickets to see Gutfeld go to
foxnews.com Gutfeld and click on the
link to join our studio audience hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else